welcome to this video playing Alpha
Centauri it feels like I played him
before but it seems that that's not the
case okay I'm going a 4 again against
the chiba nenko huh it's a very early a
5 interesting well in any case if you
take see for now he's not going to be
able to defend this so Bishop g5 is
interesting maybe 19 for here
interesting okay if he just goes 6 v
transpose to regular lines
g6 what and just blend as a pawn isn't
it what is the point of that move I
don't get it and okay it doesn't blend
up on all right it's bad anyway okay
sorry guys yeah didn't blunder the poem
because of that Bishop before resource
but it's just sucks EF blacks position
with that with that weakness on d5 so
let's see how to address that do I go
nite a tool Bishop it could have come to
be five maybe maybe that was better okay
it doesn't really matter much the
structure is just so awful I know it
gives me that pond for or not 95 what
this step is there an idea Queen
somewhere Bishop c4 it doesn't have a
pin okay I'll take it
okay just night before but should be
okay right Bishop c4 knight c6 Bishop b3
98 is that any good probably not I mean
it doesn't help and it's same so root
chicks or queen checks that's an
interesting question maybe Queen takes
Knight night before this can be five
giving me that active Queen down
okay so it takes I'll be five does that
matter much can also just grab the five
yeah maybe come on and one of those keep
it simple moves for night c forum and
the word f4 f4 to happen and now nights
night c4 and then possibly night to be
61 and you know just approaching with
the king is also good let's see also
there's also look see form as a good way
to play now maybe looks you form
and i don'ti five is fairly strong it's
not so easy to get rid of it
I don't know
what is the best way to do this
sure if you just go for worked radium
King detox you won that's not I didn't
play that too well
Luke see one you will trade and play 93
so that's not a good idea and I have to
prepare this correctly okay so whoopsie
one here or f3 and you for is also
interesting yeah 3 make some sense
anyway so is going there
it's tough to prepare you for in some
way
maybe this 4g form i have to be aware of
b5 in the right the right moment that
that could be quite an annoying move at
the moment i can take it with the tempo
so that's not really helping him but
under under different circumstances it
might happen it's that one of those
circumstances maybe time warning that
that's a move actually f7 hangs and 93
in yeah okay
yeah that's okay again look see one in
all night raid check things that are
beneficial now okay the rook trade will
loose and Roxy for is also quite strong
why did I play that so quickly that was
stupid yes tons of reserve moves are
awful are stupid is that and was that
was dumped really dumb
wow wow how idiotic it was a very easy
win and really was
I'm you can still screw it up but it's
it's okay jack so I'm I'm still winning
black hmm maybe I'm totally assessing
that endgame wrong I don't know I mean I
did I played it badly clock white and
quite clear Aang check black resides hmm
well if that must be a draw don't don't
give me that is that still a win the
engine says it's still a win I'm quite
surprised i thought i had screwed it up
and the way I played it is really
winning so why exactly yeah yeah pro
okay okay i go to d3 and he has no way
yeah i just push h5 all the time yeah I
basically robbed him of his reserve
moves if you want to call it like that
King here and now I go age 5 p.m. it is
silybin I was just disappointed that I
can't totally forgot that he has all
those reserve moves so I'm guided it was
winning in the first place for example I
can do this which is technically
speaking much much simpler probably you
know he's he's running out of moves now
I mean yes this is very easy and what is
his move I mean I can go all the way
here go age three and then just clarify
the situation
okay that there are probably multiple
wins there yeah but I didn't play that
well maybe I always kept that large
advantage but it didn't feel
particularly particularly Kelly am the
idea was to pledge for hear the engine
doesn't doesn't see anything in
particular so maybe I didn't didn't
really screw it up as much as I wasn't
was thinking now maybe it was better
than I thought but that an endgame
really deeply irritated me I totally
forgot about down about his possibility
Sam but he's running I can I can
basically make sure that he has no moves
there no reserve Tempe and then it is a
fairly easy win Yemen you know if he if
he goes here here oops here I'm just
getting to play you form and with them
and that situation always have there and
he cannot really prevent that yeah sorry
i didn't i didn't really function well
in that end game but it was win after
all okay well thanks for watching